it's probably the common good the way we
can all understand is you know is
perhaps not easy but but it it would be
something that that is above the parties
but not so far above the parties that
the parties wouldn't understand what
you're saying so it would be something
that would take into consideration say
what both liberals and conservatives
typically argue and give them give each
of them something to accept or believe
in and also something to learn or get
used to that I think is a common good
and so you could see that the common
good is very rarely practiced or made
obvious in politics only perhaps at
certain moments for example at the
beginning of a war where everyone sees
that this is an urgent challenge but the
common good is not confined to what is
urgent it's also what is most important
in the long run and that most people
don't see because they look through
partisan lenses well we have something
of that in our country the American
Founding is a political way that was set
down for the long-term good and I think
both parties now look to the
Constitution as embodying or at least
making possible a common good of course
each of them has favorite parts of the
Constitution and those favorite parts
change according to the political
situation at the moment so that's not a
complete answer but I do think that
America had a founding and a founding is
something where I'm the common good as
it's an especially in view
and there are people who are thinking
about that instead of instead of
immediate political advantage